Вітаю, з вами я – Олена Соляник,
викладачка біології школи «Майбутні».
Сьогодні з десятим класом ми розбираємо
тему: «Генетика людських популяцій».
Перш ніж ми почнемо розбиратися
з цією надзвичайно цікавою,
надзвичайно важливою для нас темою,
я хочу кілька слів сказати про
попереднє домашнє завдання.
На попередньому домашньому завданні
я просила вас поміркувати над питанням:
«Чому геномні мутації найчастіше
трапляються у рослин, аніж у тварин?».
Тут справа доволі проста, відповіді дві:
по-перше, рослина з геномними мутаціями
може не розмножуватися статевим шляхом,
а розмножуватися вегетативним шляхом.
Таким чином, мутація не буде
заважати розповсюдженню таких рослин;
відповідь друга – ці рослини
часто утворюють поліплоїдні форми.
Тобто, коли внаслідок геномної
мутації утворюються організми
з непарною кількістю хромосом,
ви знаєте, що це проблема
для подальшого утворення статевих клітин,
то рослини вирішують
це питання дуже просто:
вони просто подвоюють кількість хромосом
і такі поліплоїдні форми
можуть існувати довго.
Поліплоїдних тварин існує
дуже мало, це лічені одиниці,
тому для тварин такий
механізм не розповсюджений –
ось така мала б бути відповідь.
Ну, і до сьогоднішньої теми. Навіщо ж
вивчати генетику людських популяцій?
Чим, взагалі, популяції людини
відрізняються одна від одної?
Справа в тому, що все людство
– це один вид хомо сапіенс.
Цей вид хомо сапіенс на
всій території нашої планети,
всі особини здатні вільно
схрещуватися і давати родюче потомство.
Втім, ви знаєте, що ці
особини, хомо сапіенс,
розповсюджені на планеті нерівномірно,
також вони формують певні популяції,
якщо ми вже біологічною
мовою про це кажемо,
і ці популяції відокремлені або за
рахунок якихось природних чинників,
або за рахунок якихось
соціальних чинників.
Тобто, коли ми кажемо про генетику
якихось певних людських спільнот,
ми маємо обговорювати саме популяції.
Адже, згадаємо, що саме
популяції є одиницею еволюції,
саме на популяційному рівні
усі глобальні зміни відбуваються.
Таке цікаве питання, чи є взагалі
людська популяція ідеальною?
Нагадаємо, що ідеальною є популяція,
на яку не діють еволюційні чинники.
Тобто, це велика за
кількістю особин популяція,
всередині якої
відсутні міграції, мутації,
різні види природного
добору, дрейф генів тощо.
Тобто, якщо поміркувати, то, звісно, ні.
Людська популяція не є ідеальною,
але деякі певні закономірності
ми можемо прослідкувати
і деякі математичні моделі на
цю систему можемо накласти.
Про що йдеться?
Йдеться про те, що досліджено,
що в ідеальній популяції,
якщо ми кажемо про ознаки,
які кодуються одним геном
і, відповідно, 2 альтернативними
алелями цього гену,
то в ідеальній популяції
співвідношення цих алелів буде сталим.
Тобто, рецесивні алелі
нікуди не зникнуть,
домінантні алелі ніколи
не витіснять їх з популяції.
Ну, переносячи це питання
на людську популяцію,
наприклад, рецесивною
ознакою є світлий колір очей,
ось ця ознака ніколи з
людської популяції не зникне
або рецесивною ознакою є руде
волосся, ця ознака також не зникне,
незважаючи на те, що особин, у яких
може траплятися, дуже і дуже мало.
Ця закономірність була
помічена дуже давно,
і вона має математичний вираз ось такий,
і має назву «закон Харді-Вайнберга».
Про що це?
Дві алелі позначені різними літерами:
літерою «р» позначена домінантна алель,
літерою «q» позначена рецесивна алель.
Ось за таким співвідношенням,
тобто, маємо рівняння,
за яким співвідношення алелів «р» і
«q» в ідеальній популяції буде сталим.
Ну, звичайно, що будь-які
еволюційні фактори
будуть порушувати це співвідношення і
будемо мати відхилення від цієї моделі.
Втім, ми можемо нею користуватися
на практиці. Яким чином?
Навіщо вивчати взагалі розповсюдження
алелів у людській популяції?
Пропоную розглянути це на
ось такому практичному прикладі.
Є спадкове захворювання «фенілкетонурія»,
яке обумовлюється мутаціями
в одному-єдиному гені,
а ген цей відповідає за метаболізм
амінокислоти фенілаланіну.
За наявності такої мутації
накопичується фенілаланін,
який не може далі метаболізувати
нормальним шляхом,
продукти його токсичні,
продукти отруюють тканини,
насамперед, нервові, і це приводить
до дуже важких розумових наслідків.
Якщо це дитина, і вона росте, і в її
організмі постійний надлишок фенілаланіну,
то ці наслідки для розумових
здібностей такої дитини дуже серйозні.
Тому, важливо цю хворобу
діагностувати якомога раніше.
Медикаментозного лікування
такої хвороби не існує,
це можна скорегувати
лише за допомогою дієти,
і ці люди мають бути
позбавлені тваринних білків.
Тобто, якщо йдеться
про дитинку, про немовля,
то навіть материнське молоко
може бути для цієї дитини шкідливе.
Це дуже важливо, цю патологію
діагностувати якомога раніше
і корегувати якомога раніше,
щоб не довести до розвитку
ось таких важких наслідків.
Частота виникнення цієї патології
приблизно 1 на 10000 людей.
Як ви вважаєте – це
багато чи мало? 1 на 10000 –
ну, здавалося б, що це мало,
але для медиків важливо знати,
скільки носіїв такої патології, тобто,
скільки людей потенційно має таку мутацію.
Давайте розрахуємо, користуючись
законом Харді-Вайнберга.
Закон Харді-Вайнберга може
бути записаний ось у такому вигляді.
Перше рівняння відноситься до особин.
Тут дуже важливий аргумент –
головне не переплутати про що йдеться.
У першому рівнянні, там де
«р» і «q» піднесені до квадратів,
відноситься до особин-носіїв
тих алелів у популяції,
а друге рівняння, воно
відноситься до частоти самого алеля.
Тобто, якщо ми маємо два алеля «р» і «q»,
то разом вони складають 100 відсотків
або у долях від одиниці – одиницю.
Найважливіша помилка,
якої ви можете припуститися,
це переплутати особини та алелі.
Давайте розраховувати.
Ми маємо 1 на 10000 особин. «р» –
алель домінантна, «q» – алель рецесивна,
тобто, зараз йдеться про
«q» – алель, рецесивний алель.
1 на 10000, це 0,0001, відповідно,
частота алелей «q» в цій популяції
буде складати квадратний
корінь із цієї величини, тобто, 0.01.
Багато це чи мало? Здається, мало.
Розрахуємо тепер частоту
домінантного алеля «р».
Ми знаємо, що сума «р» та «q» дорівнює 1,
відповідно, ми можемо
розрахувати скільки ж
складає частота домінантної ознаки
«р» – 0.99, майже вся популяція.
Давайте розрахуємо
кількість носіїв. Хто такі носії?
Носії – це особини,
гетерозиготні за цією ознакою,
тобто, особини, які мають одну алель
домінантну і одну алель рецесивну,
тобто, ми маємо обрахувати величину 2 рq.
Якщо ми це розрахуємо,
одержимо ось такі величини:
дані у долях від 1 і бачимо,
що майже 2% від усієї популяції
буде мати таку дефектну
алель, буде мати таку мутацію.
Тобто, кожна 50 людина несе
дефектний мутантний алель,
який зумовлює розвиток
фенілкетонурії. Багато чи мало?
Вже не мало. Тобто, за
допомогою ось таких розрахунків
медики можуть, по-перше,
прогнозувати розповсюдження
якихось певних хвороб, ну і,
звісно, бути готовими до того,
щоб якимось чином
ліквідувати їх наслідки.
Які ж можуть бути причини,
чому алелі в людській популяції
розповсюджені нерівномірно?
Такі причини можна розділити загалом
на три групи, і ми зараз їх роздивимось.
Перша група причин – це історичні
причини, тобто, так склалося.
Як приклад вам наведено
розповсюдження алелів гену,
який зумовлює лактазну недостатність.
Ви знаєте, що не всі дорослі люди
здатні перетравлювати
лактозу, тобто, молочний цукор.
Не всі дорослі люди здатні нормально
переносити молочні продукти.
Чому так? Тому що у деяких людей,
які є носієм домінантного алелю,
лактоза перетворюється нормально,
а ось носії рецесивного алелю
лактозу перетравлювати не можуть.
Маємо чітку закономірність: одні популяції
людські мають цю проблему, інші не мають.
Якщо розібратися історично,
звідки така ситуація взялася?
Ген, який допомагає
перетравлювати лактозу,
з’явився на території країн
плодючого, родючого пів місяця,
тобто, це країни, на територіях
яких зароджувалося первинне
сільське господарство, там, де були
одомашнені перші домашні тварини
і, логічно, що ті популяції, які
навчилися одомашнювати тварин,
вони першими навчилися перетравлювати
молочні продукти навіть у дорослому віці.
Надалі так трапилося, що носії
цієї алелі із країн родючого пів місяця
розповсюдилися територією
середньої Азії та Європи,
але на Схід ці популяції не потрапили.
Тому зараз ми маємо
ситуацію, за якою європейці
здебільшого нормально
перетравлюють молочні продукти,
а ось у деяких азійських
країнах, наприклад –
Китай, Японія, маємо
з цим проблему. Чому?
Просто тому, що люди-носії відповідних
алелів до тих країн не потрапили,
тобто, причина суто історична.
Друга група причин –
це причини географічні.
Як приклад можемо розглянути алелі,
які зумовлюють потемніння кольору шкіри.
Ми знаємо, що колір шкіри –
це дія множинного алелізму,
тобто, чим більше алелів темної
шкіри буде у конкретної особи,
тим темніша буде її шкіра.
Ми знаємо, що ті люди,
які мешкають у країнах, де
дуже активна сонячна інсоляція,
де дуже відносна кількість
ультрафіолету потрапляє на шкіру,
в тих регіонах шкіра людей темніша,
і це не залежить від якихось расових,
чи то інших особливостей,
суто географічна причина,
маємо темношкірих людей у Африці,
маємо темношкірих людей європеоїдної раси
на території, наприклад,
Індії, маємо темношкірих людей
у деяких азійських країнах
та, наприклад, Австралії.
Тобто, причина суто географічна:
є ультрафіолет, від нього треба
захищатися, тому шкіра має бути темною,
тому темношкірі люди будуть
жити на таких територіях.
Відповідно, світлошкірі люди
будуть виживати на територіях
з помірним кліматом, а там світла
шкіра потрібна для того, щоб навпаки –
захоплювати більшу кількість
ультрафіолету, оскільки без ультрафіолету
не буде відбуватися
синтез вітаміну Д в організмі.
Тобто, ось таку картинку маємо,
залежить суто від, від географії.
Третя причина – це
причини епідеміологічні.
Що це таке? У тропічних
країнах розповсюджена малярія.
Це серйозна проблема, це проблема масова,
але дослідження показали,
що, наприклад, у країнах Африки,
де дійсно дуже велика
вірогідність цю малярію підхопити,
дуже велика кількість
людей є носієм гену,
який відповідає за неправильно
зібрану молекулу гемоглобіну,
так званий S-гемоглобін.
Він зумовлює серповидноклітинну анемію,
тобто, форма еритроцитів за
рахунок цього гемоглобіну неправильна.
Тобто, це не двояковвігнутий
диск, а це клітина, яка нагадує серп.
Вона не може нормально переносити
кисень ця клітина, тобто, це є патологія.
Втім, виявилося, що люди,
які мають таку патологію,
вони рідше хворіють на малярію,
тому що малярійний
плазмоній фізично не може
зайти всередину ось такого
дефектного еритроциту.
Якщо зважити ці небезпеки:
захворіти малярією і мати
серповидноклітинну анемію –
то на цих територіях виявилося, що
безпечніше мати анемію, аніж малярію.
Тому алелі, які зумовлюють
розвиток ось такої патології
розповсюдились на
територію з тропічним кліматом.
Це має дуже велике значення.
Зараз розвивається
туризм, дуже багато людей
відвідують різні країни,
в тому числі тропічні.
Дуже часте явище, коли на одній і тій
самій території аборигенне населення,
тобто, корінне населення цих
країн, не страждає так сильно
від певної хвороби, а ось туристи, які
приїжджають на територію таких країн,
дуже сильно потерпають,
і ризики захворювання
набагато більші, аніж
для місцевого населення.
Саме завдяки тому, що в тих
популяціях місцевого населення
розповсюдилися ті алелі, які
захищають від розвитку певної хвороби,
тобто, також закономірність
людської популяції.
Ну і я хочу навести ще один
приклад доволі життєвий.
Це дослідження того, яким
чином у людських популяціях
розповсюджені гени, які відповідають
за схильність чи несхильність
до, наприклад, алкоголізму. Давайте
роздивимось, яким чином це відбувається.
По-перше, алкоголь,
тобто, етиловий спирт,
в нашому організмі виробляється
постійно в якійсь певній кількості.
Це нормальний метаболіт,
він бере участь як проміжний
продукт в багатьох біохімічних реакціях.
Відповідно, якщо є такий
метаболіт, то мають бути ферменти,
які будуть його перетворювати.
Ось головні ферменти, які перетворюють
етиловий спирт в нашому організмі –
це алкогольдегідрогенази, їх дві.
Перш ніж розбиратися з
ферментами, слід розібратися з тим,
що ж відбувається з етиловим
спиртом в нашому організмі.
Етиловий спирт у нашому організмі
перетворюється наступним чином:
спочатку він перетворюється
на оцтовий альдегід
(тим, хто вивчав хімію, тому буде трошки
легше), а потім – на оцтову кислоту.
Справа в тому, що оцтовий альдегід
для нашого організму є токсичним.
Саме накопичення в організмі оцтового
альдегіду зумовлює синдроми похмілля:
головний біль, серцебиття та інші прояви.
Оцтова кислота – ацетат іони
відносно безпечні. Це нормально.
Я вже казала, що є два ферменти, які за
це відповідають.
Алкогольдегідрогеназа І
відповідає за перетворення
етилового спирту на оцтовий альдегід,
алкогольдегідрогеназа ІІ - відповідає
за перетворення оцтового альдегіду на
безпечний ацетат-іон, на оцтову кислоту.
Виявилося, що у різних
людських популяціях є різні алелі,
які відповідають за
наявність цих ферментів.
Ці ферменти є у кожного з нас,
але кожен з цих ферментів може
працювати або швидко, або повільно.
Залежно від того, який
алель буде міститися
в кожному конкретному
організмі, від цього
буде змінюватися ризик розвитку
алкоголізму протягом життя.
Давайте роздивимось, що це за алель
і яким чином все це може відбуватися.
Обидва ферменти можуть існувати,
давайте умовно їх назвемо швидкими та
повільними, активними або неактивними.
Якщо ми маємо два ферменти,
комбінації може бути чотири.
Обидва ферменти швидкі,
якщо трапляється ось така
комбінація: швидкий – швидкий,
то спирт дуже швидко
перетворюється на альдегід,
альдегід дуже швидко
перетворюється на кислоту,
тобто, ця людина навіть не встигає
відчути сп'яніння, як вже тверезішає.
Такій людині взагалі не
має сенсу вживати алкоголь,
оскільки вона не отримає того
ефекту, задля чого все це відбувається.
Такі люди ніколи не стануть алкоголіками,
і ось такі алелі, ось
така комбінація алелів
розповсюджена, наприклад,
у країнах Південної Америки.
Чому так відбувається?
Так сталося історично:
тропічні країни, тропічні фрукти,
сонце активне, фрукти бродять –
тобто ці люди історично вживали
якусь більшу кількість алкоголю,
тому їх ферменти пристосувалися
до того, щоб швидко їх метаболізувати.
Розглянемо інший варіант.
Перша алкоголь дегідрогеназа
швидка, а інша – друга – повільна.
Що відбувається за таких умов?
Швидко утворюється оцтовий альдегід,
але він дуже повільно
перетворюється на оцтову кислоту.
Тобто, така людина відчуває
швидке і дуже тяжке похмілля,
яке більш тривале, ніж у інших людей.
Вони також не ризикують стати
алкоголіками, тому що немає сенсу.
Синдроми похмілля переважають над
тими ефектами, що дає власне алкоголь.
Розглянемо тепер ситуацію, за
якою перший фермент повільний,
другий фермент швидкий.
Перший фермент повільний,
тобто, етанол, який ми вживаємо,
довго циркулює у
організмі і дуже повільно
перетворюється на
токсичний оцтовий альдегід.
Тобто, така людина буде
відносно довго у нетверезому стані,
а похмілля у неї відбудеться дуже швидко.
Ця група людей, вона має
найбільший ризик розвитку алкоголізму.
Тобто, людям із співвідношенням
ось таких от алелів.
Звичайно, що не можна стати алкоголіком,
якщо ти не вживаєш спиртні напої.
Це очевидний факт. Втім, якщо
спиртні напої вживаються такою людиною,
то розвиток алкоголізму
надзвичайно високий.
Ну і останній варіант, коли
повільні обидва ферменти.
Такі люди здатні вживати
велику кількість алкоголю,
але потім у них будуть розвиватися
доволі тривалі наслідки
вживання цього алкоголю.
Тобто, тут ризик розвитку
алкоголізму середній.
Як бачите, у різних людських
популяціях характерне більш активне
чи менш активне відношення
до алкогольних напоїв.
Як ви знаєте з історії,
корінне населення Америки,
американські індійці, вони
дуже швидко спивалися
і готові були заради
вогняної води віддати все –
і землі, і золото, і все,
що в них було. Чому?
Швидше за все тому, що в їх
популяціях була розповсюджена
ось така комбінація алелів, яка
«допомогла» їм стати алкоголіками.
Такої проблеми не було,
доки не з’явилися європейці
із своїми міцними спиртними напоями.
Коли ця ситуація була спровокована,
то вона вже почала
розвиватися дуже активно.
Тобто, приходимо до того,
що людські популяції різні,
різні комбінації алелів, які
розповсюджені в популяціях,
можуть відповідати за
різні стадії метаболізму,
за розвиток різних хвороб, за прояв
якихось зовнішніх ефектів абощо.
Звичайно, що це треба вивчати,
і, звичайно, генетика
дуже активно з цим працює.
За допомогою вивчення
співвідношення різних алелів у популяції
можна вивчити стійкість до
певних хвороб на певних територіях.
Зараз існує навіть такий
напрямок у медицині, у фармації,
як таргетна розробка ліків, тобто,
адресна, для якихось певних популяцій.
Є медикаменти, які
діють на одну групу людей
і не діють на іншу
популяцію саме завдяки тому,
що мішенню для цих
ліків є молекули, які різні
в різних людських популяціях.
Відповідно, якщо всі молекули в
нашому організмі кодуються генами,
то, відповідно, маємо різні
алелі, які відповідають за розвиток
різних білкових комплексів
всередині нашої молекули.
Є навіть американська асоціація СDС –
це організація контролю над
розповсюдженням різних захворювань.
Вони навіть рекомендують вживати певну
групу ліків для популяції певних людей.
Якщо не розуміють причини,
за яких це відбувається,
то можуть відбуватися
різні неадекватні дії.
Наприклад, була описана
ситуація, коли один з препаратів
був рекомендований для
лікування афроамериканців
і, водночас, не був рекомендований
для іншого населення Америки.
Це здійняло такий галас
на рівні хайпу, а як же ж так –
дискримінують за расовою ознакою,
і ліки для чорних, і ліки для білих,
чому це, навіщо. Насправді,
причина була суто біологічна.
Причина була в тому, що
мішень, на яку розробляли ці ліки,
була присутня у популяції
тих афроамериканців,
і була відсутня в інших популяціях.
Тобто, незнання біологічних
особливостей в таких випадках
призводить до викривлення, взагалі,
розуміння навіть співвідношення
і взаємин між різними людьми. Однак
лишаємося на біологічному світогляді.
Із сьогоднішньою темою це все.
Наступного разу ми поговоримо
більш докладно про те,
яким же чином медицина
використовує ці знання,
і які програми працюють із діагностики,
із лікування, із консультування.
Зараз пропоную вам домашнє завдання.
Є деякі популяції людини, у яких
спостерігається висока частота
рідкісних алелів для інших популяцій.
Поміркуйте, будь ласка, що
це за алелі, що це за популяції
і за яких умов така
ситуація може відбутися.
Ну і поговоримо про
це на наступному уроці.
Дякую, побачимось!